stand up and run around okay good call
for the last four and places stretches
and action bar
[Music]
have you guys wondered since we got hit
with the Corona hella hard how come Batz
a [ __ ] up hypothesis they don't know
if it a hundred percent came from an
animal but if it is if it did come from
bats how come things mosquitoes can
carry all the diseases and not die from
them yeah [ __ ] do they stay alive well
maybe that's what's happening in the
batsman they can carry the disease and
that it be affected by it maybe it
doesn't [ __ ] them up that hard but when
it enters a human we die because that's
like kind of how a lot of the flus
happen because it come from pigs and
then the pigs they kind of live with it
but then like for us we die yeah so this
is the really interesting part is that
did you know that humans and bats
actually share 96% of the same genome we
sure that way I mean that we can
reproduce with bats yes that's exactly
you could try it a couple times you take
a real bat nabob oh yeah real Batman
Batman hell of the virus 3 yeah but I
need a wingman for that that's crazy
this is a reason why I guess if Corona
did come from bats wife [ __ ] with us so
hard
so when bats fly they release a ton of
energy and their body temperature goes
to 38 to 41 degrees Celsius which is
like over a hundred degrees Fahrenheit
for a fever I mean it's the same what's
the same as us we have a fever so
usually we go into a fever if we're
trying to kill a pathogen mm-hmm but
since if this virus did come from a bat
the virus is able to live at such a high
temperature so which is why when we have
a fever this also does nothing - oh no
that's why it's the big scary dude look
could this like any hatful I live
edition
let's plan around out a hundred
something is that what happens naturally
when when we get like hot summer fever
the temperature kills off things I saw
you when you have a fever what it's
trying to do is whatever a pathogen
bacterial infection or viral infection
is your body elevates the temperature
because if it's living at like 95 to 98
degrees which our bodies at if you
elevate it your body's trying to go like
oil this [ __ ]
you know so usually after a fever you
feel good and then you kill whatever so
virus infects all bacteria they don't
survive hmm huh but not this corona as
parasites that's another one hmm we try
to burn that [ __ ] to the ground
interesting yeah man that seems like a
little bit of dangerous to me I was
reading about murder hornets because
remember like they were really scary we
kill wasps and bees and [ __ ] right yeah
yeah but there's this like one colony of
bees if that's used to living with
murder Hornets oh they they're used to
them being around and being hunted by
them so there's a scout murder Hornet
that comes and tries to find the
beehives and the once it finds a beehive
the these bees are so smart and they got
so evolved to like come for them this
predator yeah so they have like four
bees that go out and like Lori into the
Beehive yeah and then it finally gets it
it's huge it's like way bigger than the
bees and it gets into the Beehive and
then they kind of like go like this
they're kind of taunting it and then it
they wait for it to attack one of them
and then all of them just start piling
on to this thing they dogpile it and
there's so many bees on top of this
wasps or the murder order that it boils
it alive all from the temperature yeah
from the temperature and then they go
out and they're just being it or
something are they going like a vibrator
right yeah they're all over it anything
in it yes so hot that it dies but then
the bees can survive they only have one
degree higher that they can survive over
this Hornet so they get it to just that
degree and then once again about the die
first that first be the alert a man for
sure doesn't make it though yeah yeah
there's like four and then like one of
those four die for sure yeah and then
they're trained to go out and like the
Scout leaves little scent marks to tell
the other Hornets where the hive is so
they go and they eat all of the scent
marks so that like it's all the tracks
are gone Oh nature's cooler [ __ ] smart
they work in teams yeah they all like
they really taking it for the team we
gotta learn from the bees yeah like no
literally like die for the Queen you
know especially that first one the
sacrifices arrived so I gotta jump boom
yeah no frontlines like [ __ ] there's
like four on the front line it's like
one of us gonna die but it's gonna be
worth it yeah I like this it's like
nature war [ __ ] you know it's like
reverse counter moves all this [ __ ]
speaking of nature war [ __ ] I saw the
special a long time ago on like sperms
when sperms are in like in China ball
shuttin no no no when they're in in like
the when they're trying to get to the
egg yeah I saw a thing where a sperm ran
into a sperm from another guy and they
[ __ ] like rewards you and and what
okay so one was like chillin and the
other one went [ __ ] cameras gotta
care about the girls just like would
know like we're gonna put a camera in
there we're gonna have this guy nut in
you and then we're gonna have this guy
nut in yes so microscopes [ __ ] right so
there's a sperm chillin this one goes
swims off and this one's like yes and
like it was another situation where a
bunch of sperm from the other guy built
like a [ __ ] sperm wall so the other
guy's sperm couldn't get to the egg
[ __ ] brains as I a sperm cell then
like what the [ __ ] they have only minor
their own I think they know how to
[ __ ] that's the same yeah bro it's
crazy that that makes a human guys have
to join an egg and then they murdered
before they even became human should be
an Olympic sport to guys now and who's
who's had a new microscope watch all
right and we're a [ __ ]
she's got to do it yeah you gotta do it
I'm a whole nine month and you gotta
train your sperm and sperm Wars yeah
we're probably going see your boss huh
probably get rid of the steroids sure
yeah my playing Starcraft dude you just
get a [ __ ] army and they're just
killing each other have you guys ever
thought so I think as a dude you always
like figure out like you gauge either it
predicts big or small or if it works or
not would you rather have a dick that
doesn't work butts huge or it's small
but it works like when you're trying to
make a baby right there's actually a lot
of pressure
cuz I you're thinking like like like
okay cool you guys have sex like I hope
you got the it works this time and you
impregnate the lady yeah and then if it
doesn't sometimes you kind of get sad
actually for me I get on yourself put me
and Jill we're trying for the second
time and then her period comes quickly
as the first time I want my dick to feel
good so whatever that option is so
you're saying doesn't work is then can't
get a girl pregnant or doesn't work is
in Kenya hard can't get the girl
pregnant
oh the balsakhi I don't know I think
that depends on the person that they
want to have kids or know that this
feels good if you can get it I'd rather
have a smaller size are we talking about
two of the extremes though like one is a
horse dick and one is a micropenis Oh
would you rather have a horse dick or
micropenis a majority guy Jacob hoppin
what about the girl yeah whatever stick
with your boat size horse cleaner Mike
okay no no my answers no well I think
the girl covilhã is extremely massive
boobs or just flat uh
and you can't get implants I don't know
no extremely that's good fixed removes
but if you get pregnant or tight as hell
but you can or no place that wasn't
always good either it doesn't feel good
even though I think that boo born is
good I don't know I guess I'm the wrong
guy I never wanted a big boost so you
rather be like super flat I like my boob
size yeah the same way I would like my
like I would
ever want like I've done great with my
like what the penis I've been blessed
with yeah I had a love-hate as a kid cuz
I would see all my friends and I'll be
like my dick don't look to say man and I
was like dad was my dick so different
it's like oh it's cuz you're not
circumcised ah can I be circumcised then
he goes not only spend any money you
should be happy I know now with all the
research it's coming out musically no
wallace's yeah yes so I was yeah I
wanted to be like all my friends cuz
every time we peed and cross dreams and
shared I would look over and I'm like
Maddox what's gonna get circumcised when
I was 12
why cuz you felt different I felt
different when you were 12 yeah cuz I
that's when I like I started to really
notice it looked different and then my
mom I think she had like the tumor or
something like it and so she got that
cut off so she was like well I'm this
person does do plastic surgery so they
can circumcise you and then for some
reason like this lady had Taemin like a
like a photo album or for patients of
dicks of just different things she's
done her op and then one of them was
this dick that's wrapped up in gauze and
then so she was like so I do have a
patient that was also around your aged I
wanted to get circumcised and so she's
walking me through the process and I
just just thinking about how many no
reason boners I got at that time and how
there's gonna be like stitches or like a
wound and every time I was gonna get a
no reason boner I could just imagine my
dick just like blood squirting their
[ __ ] off to stitch it I'm right now
I'm good wait both y'all answer up sighs
yeah you too
no services oh you're so gosu use that
second side you're on certain side as
well are you good to make sure yeah okay
I had a friend that uh he was a doctor
too but then he uh he had this condition
where as an adult it tighten up right
and then so the the penis I couldn't go
through it anymore right so he get
circumcised and he was like dude it's
way different in terms of how it feels
being serviced really he goes dude I'm
like wait because now it's rubbery I
guess everything that's weighed
desensitized Wow like that now just I'll
never experience that interesting what
are you five circumcised I have a whole
tree of normal penis oh yeah
regular aesthetically pleasing penis I
have my case on mine yeah yeah different
strokes for different folks different
strokes for different folks no shame
Jana wanna give away with Steve is but
he'll tell us yeah he told us he was
half when we first started like I made
sure I was like I want to ask well like
every time you see it explain please
it looks more uncircumcised than
circumcised but when it's soft and how
did that happen because when they were
doing the circumcision the doctor [ __ ]
up when he was a baby
good encourage he was in he was just
crying so much that his dad was like
just let it's fine like just yeah they
they they [ __ ] up Wow but like he I
think it's better like I don't know like
you at the bicep before yeah and
honestly like up all the guys I've had
ever had sex with like he just seems to
enjoy it more and I don't know if that's
like a connection thing but enjoy the
sex more like it just seems like when
you start do it go and do an oral or any
sort of action on it was it a just yeah
he seems like he's just feeling it way
more hey what's a combo psychological
and physical so he probably loves you I
mean I guess we'll never know how what
the other like type of penis goes there
I would want to know I think to find out
you have to not touch it like a year
what yeah no it probably made to like be
uncircumcised and then get circumcised
then you could know that I like the
themes doctor but exactly and then when
you have a baby and then like do or do
you want to circumcise it and you when
you see just the shots and how much the
baby's crying really you're just like oh
hell
that's the reason why I'm not
circumcised my dad was like it looks
painful because the baby gets shots and
all these shots are in just to hear all
these crying ass babies and all that my
wife decided yeah I have a friend of a
friend her her vagina hole was so tight
like so small that she couldn't like
have sex comfortably like that happened
to me so what yeah okay
she had a but the surgical procedure
done Oh wide in her hole because she
couldn't have sex it was that bad but
yeah was that bad but the [ __ ] doctor
stupid [ __ ] up why didn't her urethra
what her [ __ ] pee hole why pee
everywhere whoever would want that it
got nobody
what the [ __ ] so he like [ __ ] up widen
her [ __ ] she woke up was like if
something was not right they had to like
you know reverse everything and then she
had like she had like a catheter and
like all that [ __ ] she's fine now I feel
like the feeling the boyfriend is like
[Laughter]
he can't even have sex though
it's so tight where it's uncomfortable
like it's not exist so many times to
lose my virginity and a hurt like [ __ ]
every time we ever tried it for like
years and even now like if it goes more
than a week it's like it tightens back
yeah yeah like pretty like it go pretty
slow to go get it like yeah it's painful
for the girl too but then it feels good
yeah there are the ladies out there that
I was aquick I was like
[Music]
[Music]